the growing fallout over the Kate
Steinle verdict and the shock and
outrage over the acquittal of her killer
on murder charges it all boils down to
this
Kate's killer should have never been in
the country Hosea Nez Garcia Zarate who
was previously deported from the u.s.
five times was in a position to kill
only because of a San Francisco insane
sanctuary city status and by the way
he's hardly alone twenty-two percent of
the federal inmate population in
California are suspected illegal
immigrants 121 criminal aliens released
by ice between 2010 and 2014 were later
charged with homicide that's blood on
their hands my friends and 2139 daca
recipients have lost permits because of
criminal or public safety concerns now
everybody wants to say the dreamers
represent the best of the young people
in the country you know every dreamer is
a valedictorian or saves cats from trees
but is that true well they've
experienced the painful and personal
consequences of loss and death due to
our insane immigration policies I'm
talking about the victims of crimes
because they've experienced these
personal consequences of loss and death
and life and death lost Don Rosenberg is
joining us in Westlake Village
California he lost his son the 25 year
old drew when he was killed in 2010 by a
Honduran who entered the country
illegally but earned protected status
and joining us from Chicago Bryan
McCain's brother Dennis was killed in
2010 by a drunk driving illegal
immigrant and in Phoenix Steve Ronan
Beck's
son 21 years old Grant was working
overnight on a shift at a convenience
store when he was basically executed by
an illegal immigrant over a pack of
cigarettes gentlemen I wanted to talk to
all of you since this Kate Steinle
verdict came down and I think Steve I
want to go to you first because as I
understand it your son's murderer is
awaiting trial at this moment your
reaction to the Kate Steinle
acquittal yesterday you know I was
absolutely stunned
and after that it was just heartbroken
for the Steinle family I know that I can
speak for for Don and Brian and all the
other victims families that our hearts
go out to the Steinle family it's just a
travesty it you know this man gave
several different stories as to what
actually happened he never gave an
honest answer they still don't know
exactly how he got the gun but then they
acquit him of murder or even
manslaughter
it's it's I don't know I I can't wrap my
head around it Bob I want to go to you
the loss whether it's a drunk driving
illegal immigrant a hit-and-run illegal
immigrant involuntary manslaughter
although this this creep didn't even get
that in the Steinle case he's getting
off basically scot-free and a couple
more months of times after time served
what does this tell you about daca and
all the concern now about the daca
recipients in the United States you saw
those figures you know him well
well I gotta tell ya let's go to Bob on
that Brian you mean you mean you I'm
sorry let's go let's go to Brian on that
sorry Brian okay yeah well it's it's
outrageous and and it could have
happened here in Chicago as well because
we were one of the leading sanctuary
cities that have became a model for the
country
I bet the Stanley's a few years ago
there are wonderful people my heart goes
out to them they've they fought the good
fight as we all have just the travesty
of justice it's so many of us can lay
claim to the proverbial insult to injury
and it continues almost every day
there's hundreds of thousands of
American family members every day that
mourn the loss of their their children
and their siblings and their spouses so
with the Steinle are our prayers are
with them and with San Francisco god
help you out there
I don't know what's going on I was it
that was in I went to that pier last
summer with my wife just just to try
doesn't get some sense of what of what
it was like and it was it was tragic
indeed Don let's go to you speaking of
San Francisco your son was law school in
San Francisco
back in 2010 he's no longer here to
enjoy a holiday season your reaction and
then what about we've heard nothing from
Nancy Pelosi we've heard nothing from
Hillary Clinton nothing from prominent
prominent Democrats on this case zero
well I'll tell you I wasn't actually
shocked in the least bit I expected this
to happen I live out here I see what
happens every day so I wasn't shocked at
the at the to acquittals on the murder
charges I was marginally surprised that
he didn't get the involuntary
manslaughter particularly since that's
what the defense was using is their
claim that it was an accident but even
with that you know it's it's San
Francisco and the jury you know it's OJ
Simpson jury we're not going to we're
not going to convict you no matter what
I will tell you though you know you
mentioned Nancy Pelosi and you can you
know lay it on all the Democrats it's
inconceivable to me and I find it
reprehensible that they're worried about
daca recipients I mean the worst thing
that what happened to any of those guys
would be they get deported the worst
thing that's happened to you know Steve
and Bryne myself and so many others is
they've lost a loved one so our position
and you know there's an organization we
started called a V AK back in in June
and we put out a position that daca
should not even be discussed until all
the other illegal immigration issues are
dealt with so for them to talk about
shutting down the government is just
absolutely Chuck Schumer actually to
shut down the government because he
cares more about handling and caring and
the feeding of illegal immigrants than
protecting the innocent lives of
Americans
and legal immigrants in the United
States because there there are plenty of
other prospective victims out there
because of San Francisco's sanctuary
city policies California's state
policies Chicago sanctuary city policies
and it goes on and on and on into all
three of you I will say this tonight my
heart breaks for you our viewers hearts
breaks right for you my radio listeners
Americans are infuriated by this and the
fact that politicians in both parties
don't seal this border build this wall
get this stuff done to protect us is an
abomination it has been for years
and now with this latest verdict it's
even worse well you know Laura we we
can't rely on the politicians out in
California they made the best
so I'm actually announcing a little
early earlier than we had planned but we
we're gonna launch an initiative to not
only repeal the sanctuary City or the
sanctuary state bill that was just
passed but to also create law that
requires law enforcement to cooperate
with with ice and with the Federals good
federal officers so I tell you if
anybody wants to look the state's not
really completely done yet but it fights
sanctuary city fights the bank excuse me
fight sanctuary state calm and we can
really use people's help Facebook and
Twitter all right we'll get it right I'd
do that too late at night but we'll get
we'll get it thank you very much [ __ ]
Twitter we got to get the word out
people have to take the power back from
the politicians who will not listen
Steve I want to go to you because when I
think about you you're not too far from
Phoenix correct
you're right you're yeah okay so you're
not too far from the border what what do
Arizonans the average person on the
street I don't care if you're Hispanic
white black what's the average person on
the street think of special treatment
being given to people who break our laws
and repeatedly come into our country are
deported come back commit crimes and
then get a slap on the wrist and any
sense from people in Arizona about this
you know I a lot of my friends people I
work with even even
people that I just meet that that
recognize me
you know they're they're fed up they're
they're tired of it it's you know it's
not just the murder of my son or the
murder of Mary Ann Mendoza's son or
Don's or Bryan's it's it's the drugs
that are coming across its the human
trafficking all human yeah and and the
the ones that are coming across the
border that are taking advantage of our
social service systems hospitals having
children here having multiple children
here and you know we can't calm anchor
babies I'm sorry but the they're here
it's nine months pregnant they have
their child and then no one can ever
deport them look gentlemen we're out of
time but I want to say to all of you
we're we're with you the people of the
country are with you is probably of
little comfort to you now given what's
happened but thank you so much for
joining us and we're gonna be following
every aspect of this case and others
like it sadly as the days and weeks go
on